j'ai eu le souffle coupé
que j'ai été nouvelle dans l'émission
mais bon passons on a eu un épisode dans
une piscine où on a eu un on a partagé
un baiser c'est vrai et je pensais que
c'était une démarche Visante à nous
réconcilier sauf que depuis plus rien
dans cette piscine bah en fait la paix
était déjà scellée avait déjà été décidé
donc oui moi j'adore le débat je suis
enflammée je suis jusqu'au boutiste je
suis entière j'ai beaucoup de différence
comme une noisette mais encore une fois
je n'ai aucune espèce de rancoeur ou
d'amertume et surtout je suis pas du
tout rancunière donc il y avait aucun
problème donc comme tu es américaine et
comme je crois dans la contre-culture
américaine il y avait un slogan c'est
fait l'amour pas la guerre bah allons-y
[Applaudissements]